Pulitzer prize-winning columnist and
cable news pundit Charles Krauthammer
died yesterday he was 68 years old
friends and colleagues at Fox News in
the Washington Post remembered him as
one of the generations leading
conservative voices Anthony Mason is
here with a look back at Scott hammers
life and work Anthony good morning good
morning Charles Krauthammer had been
battling cancer and had not appeared on
Fox News since last August in a note to
readers earlier this month
Krauthammer revealed his cancer had
returned and he only had only weeks to
live
writing quote this is the final verdict
my fight is over in the end everything
all the beautiful elegant things in life
depend ultimately on getting politics
right Charles Krauthammer faced many
battles throughout his life a diving
accident while in medical school at
Harvard left him paralyzed I was sure I
was there but he still managed to
graduate on time and at the top of his
class he later gave up psychiatry you're
betraying your whole life if you don't
say what you think and you don't say
honestly and bluntly and followed his
love of politics to Washington I thought
once I'm in Washington isn't that where
they do politics Krauthammer was a
leading advocate for the Iraq war we
have to attack him where they are he
also didn't shy away from challenging
fellow conservatives I think denial is
what you do for yourself yes as a way to
get through life I'm not sure it's the
way a party ought to get through
politics and he often expressed
criticism of President Trump well our
time he spent discussing this rodeo
clown a bee Stoddard has appeared on Fox
News's special report panel with
Krauthammer since 2009 he just was
calling him like he seed them and he was
willing to take it from people who
didn't like that because the thing that
he couldn't bear was to not be honest
when he needed a break from politics
Krauthammer would unwind at Nationals
Park
we need happy news like this this is why
God created the baseball Krauthammer is
survived by his wife Robin's son Daniel
and his mother Thea when he announced he
had just weeks to live he said he had no
regrets writing I am sad to leave but I
leave with the knowledge that I lived
the life that I intended the Nationals
had a moment of silence for him last
night in the stadium and I know he'd
appreciate that I went to read his
letter after I saw that he had written
one there's something the word strike
you very differently when you know the
person is writing it knowing that they
don't have much time left on this it's
not often you get a chance to write that
letter which is fortunate that he did
but I encourage everybody to go look at
a tweet Nash Jenkins he covers Congress
for Time magazine his father had an
accident he'd only met Krauthammer and
only met him once
his father had an accident that gave him
a spinal cord injury and Krauthammer
wrote him a two-page letter basically
saying I know what it's like and life
will get better it's gonna be okay it's
a very it's a it's a touching letter he
never wanted to be judged by that injury
which was also another remarkable thing
about him Thank You Anthony